the first talkity after they talked to
us little Cooper Berg's collimation
versus C sizes yes alright thanks
everybody or welcome back from lunch so
this is the shore of the Cesar Chavez
park down here in Berkeley but sometimes
we need to quantum you want to go to the
shore and sometimes you want to go to
take Cooper Burke so I'll start with the
conclusions just the bottom line
and what this is all about so that the
the talk and the work is about the
concrete
cost of Cooper Burak algorithm on
various sea side parameters that have
been proposed and the kind of top line
conclusion is that the parameters that
were proposed are offering you
relatively little quantum security
beyond the cost of quantumly evaluating
the group action itself on a uniform
superposition okay so what do we mean by
this well for example for seaside 512
which was which is the lowest proposal
lowest parameters proposed you can do
this key recovery in about 2 to the 16
evaluations of the Oracle if you use
about 2 to the 40 bits of what's called
Quantum accessible Ram and relatively
small other computational resources so 2
to the 40 bits is 128 gigabytes which I
think I have in my laptop so that's a
pretty small amount although you do have
to make it quantum accessible and I'll
talk about that so the main you know
conclusions from the work have to do
with the number of Oracle calls that you
have to make for for this these Cooper
burg style sieve attacks but people also
want to know ok what does that mean
actually for the concrete security
claims so I will say something like this
if you make the assumption that these
Oracle evaluations do not cost much more
than the for the best case which which
Chloe was telling us about in the in the
talk crate prior to this before lunch if
under this assumption you end up with
some some rough estimates like this
seaside 512 would be breakable with
about 2 to the 60
t-gates and other cheaper Clifford gates
and that would mean that it would fall
well short of the claimed or targeted
missed level one post quantum security
so for NIST level one you need to be
secure against attacks by quantum
circuits with at least two to the 170
over max depth circuit sorry T gates or
quantum gates and max depth is said to
range reasonably between two of the 40
and through to the 96 so if you plug
this in you need to be quite a bit above
the 2 to the 60 threshold that that we
would get here so you can say okay but
what if we would go to higher parameters
C said 1024 it turns out the numbers
don't change all that much they go up
you know a little bit moderately but not
too much so now for example we can do
breaking it with to 272 T gates and
about 2 to the 44 bits of this quantum
accessible Ram that also leaves it short
of level 1 if you go up higher 1792 was
also proposed actually proposed for nist
level 3 but it turns out you can break
it with about 2 to the 80 40 gates and
this much key ram or key rack'em
basically this puts it pretty close or a
little uncomfortably close to whether it
reaches level 1 or not it's not totally
clear what the conclusion is here
because at the high end of max depth of
2 to the 96 this is more than you need
but at lower ends of max depth this is
less than what you're supposed to be
security 1 is as secure as aes 128 key
search
and this guidance says this is what they
estimate aes-128 key searches yeah why
isn't that to 264 because that the key
search has to actually count the cost of
the AES Oracle as well I looked up the
estimates the AES Oracle was about a
million like sorry two to the 20g gates
or so I guess is according to estimate I
saw with a depth of two to the 15
so there's a big substantial cost just
to evaluate AES in the context of a
quantum key search and then there's also
NIST has this restriction on max depth
which says we actually want to consider
attacks which have some bound on how
deep they are and so between two to the
forty on the low end and two to the
ninety six is the the range of
parameters and if you limit the depth of
your quantum attack your AES key search
is actually slower and worse so in order
to match the AES key key search hardness
this is what NIST is advising I'm call
it Q ROM qrow M so quantum read-only
memory Cooper Briggs paper Greg he uses
the Q Rackham
so that's quantum randomly accessible
classical memory so it's ordinary bits
like I'm you know the RAM of your laptop
but the abstraction is that you can
access it in superposition so that you
can address it with a quantum state and
then the lookup gives you back a quantum
state which is like a superposition of
the memory contents yeah exactly so yeah
so these estimates here include the cost
of implementing Q rackham with ordinary
RAM and a very simple linear search over
over the RAM there's a paper by a big
group from Google from a couple years
ago which tells you you can do this
quite modest cost basically four times
the number of cells in the queue rack'em
because all post quantum schemes the
most secure because a yeah so one way to
be as secure is AES is to just break a
yes quantumly and now everybody is as
secure is a yes so so this could be a
bit of a moving target I don't know the
you know the current state of the yard
on this but one five seven okay it
doesn't change this conclusion I know if
it changes this conclusion probably not
at least not at the low end of next step
maybe it might change this assessment
here yeah so then you'd have to redo the
the analysis the NIST you know guide I'm
going by what the NIST guidance says
which is they count the quantum gates
I'm also treating t gates as more
expensive than other linear Clifford
gates the number of linear gates is
comparable to what you see here so
that's not going to be vice versa so
again the focus of the talk and the work
is actually not on this at all I'm just
plugging in the known bounds that we
have for the for the evaluation of the
Oracle because people want to know but
it's actually not like what I'm doing
here it's not what the work is about so
you know if you prefer a different model
or a different count for the what NIST
level one means or what a different
different evaluation method for the
Oracle you would get
yes I just wanted to say in response to
question alternate models when I when I
first thought about Rocco which actually
was just secondly this just
philosophically it seemed like there
could be various alternate architectures
specific to Cuba and that it should be
separate accounting and including acne
for all I know much cheaper than these
estimates the only thing is when I asked
experimentalist they had no particular
ideas at this time so so anything you
want to say alternate architectures
yeah that's I think that's an important
part we have an upper bound on how much
Kuryakin costs that that's been
established but it's a it's a it's a
model it's a memory model of its own
that it's kind of you could just treat
it as a complexity resources great so
that's why I want to focus on like
statements of the form item to here
saying how many evaluations and how much
Q Rackham do you need to to have a
successful
so good so we've already seen this
morning so I'll go relatively quickly
over the background but so seaside vac a
strict long Martindale Panty and renas
is this commutative group action and we
have an abelian group G and some
arbitrary set Z and the action I'll
denote by star it takes from an element
of G element of Z into into Z and I just
want to point out that s ith like David
was telling us about earlier is
different it doesn't fall into this
framework there's not there's really no
group action there's not an abelian
group at all but allows you to get
diffie-hellman key exchange as we saw
before lunch the important thing is that
once public key would be like a star Z
and B star Z for some public parameter Z
and then the shared key you would get is
a plus B times Z I'm using additive
notation for the group so that just
falls out and what's cool about seaside
you get this pretty good efficiency
especially in terms of space so you have
64 byte keys for example and then I
guess the ad needs to be updated it's
gotten a little faster 50 or 60
milliseconds
and then they've also been signature
proposals that have come out of this in
in recent years starting from the Alban
AUVs
ideas and they're the public key plus
the signature size is smaller than all
the current nist proposals for post
quantum signatures so in terms of size
of you know cipher texts or signature
keys this is doing quite well especially
relative to the competition so how do we
attack seaside quantumly so the
statement that we're gonna go after is
secret key recovery so given the base
point or the the public parameters e and
then someone's public key a star Z we'd
like to find their secret key a or some
equivalent of it and I guess David
wanted to credit this to Greg but Greg
didn't want the credit it seems to me
the credit has typically gone to this
paper by shells Joe and sukharev which
shows how to do the secret key recovery
by reducing to this hidden shift problem
alright so we'll say a bit more about
that a moment but what what what can we
do with hidden shift well starting with
Cooper burger no three there are these
algorithms that will solve hidden chef
problems efficiently or sorry not
efficiently quantumly so the basic
structure of these algorithms is that we
have some kind of Oracle which is out
going to output these random labelled
quantum states ok so you get you get a
quantum state and you get some label
that the Oracle gives you and Oracle
does this by evaluating the group action
on some uniform superposition over the
group and then there's some sieve
algorithm which will combine these
labelled States in various ways
intelligently to generate somehow more
favorable states are nicer States
finally once the states have been made
very nice then we do some measurement on
this very favorable state to recover one
or more bits of hidden shift which is
this that's the general structure and
then there have been various algorithms
fitting under the structure so Cooper
Berg's original takes two to the order
square root little n Oracle queries and
quantum bits this little n is the log of
the
sighs soon after raiga gave a variant of
this algorithm which uses only
polynomial number of quantum bits so
this there's an exponential improvement
in the quantum space but some increase
in the exponent in a number of Oracle
queries and then a follow-up so the
third algorithm by Cooper burg first
first put out in late 2011 manages to
get to to the back to the to to the
square root n order square root n Oracle
queries but not qubits anymore but
rather bits of Q Rackham so still we're
in this or maybe we're kind of in this
middle ground of it's not quite
classical memory it's not quite quantum
memory it's mostly classical with a
quantum twist to it so and you're back
down to this asymptotically smaller
regime of number of Oracle queries okay
so that's the the kind of top line
results or complexities of these
algorithms but if you look a bit closer
and and and Kubrick actually points this
out in his paper that this third
algorithm here actually subsumes the
prior to the other to come out as
instantiations of it and it also offers
more trade-offs among the parameters and
one trade-off that will really kind of
squeeze a lot of juice out of is this
trade-off which is that you can
essentially as long as this equation
hold so as long as the log of your
number of queries times the log of your
amount of Q rack'em is roughly exceeding
n then you're the sieve will will work
so what we'll do is get some some
leverage out of the case where okay if
our queries are very expensive than you
really want to drive the number of
queries down you can do that by
correspondingly lifting up the amount of
Q rack'em that's available and then it's
a balancing act but you know when
queries are very expensive q Rackham is
probably not that expensive or we know
an upper bound on how expensive it is
and so just kind of balance these things
better and you get a nicer
it does not so this this equation is for
Cooper birds this is a new trade-off
available only in Cooper burg 11 which
the prior to do not have and that's
where we're gonna get some leverage so
that you know if you want to know like
what's what's kind of the key idea or
the key lever point it's it's this kind
of equation yeah I don't even I'm gonna
live with air t2 for the talk but be
glad to talk offline about
it is hired it's it's it's kind of very
high arity right yeah so but as what I
mean by this is that this trade-off here
doesn't really make sense for the prior
two algorithms just because it's not
even talking about Kira those aren't
even dealing with key Rock'em
how much quantum memory do you need yeah
yeah
so there are okay so Q Rackham is
classical memory
there's also associated so there's Polly
logarithmic quantum memory associated to
this the sieve as well it's it's quite
quite low no I don't think so the
associated qubits for February 11 is
it's gonna be log times the depth of the
log yeah most of the qubits are in the
Oracle yeah yeah I mean you want to
account for if you want to account for
how much how many qubits the civets self
needs yeah we have formulas for that
it's some small poly log term yeah one
one factor of log and then times the
depth I think of this is
as we're holding the phase vectors
there's some so that's a picture now we
can apply this to Seaside or really
everything we say applies generally to
any CRS style commutative group action
so there's nothing specific to Seaside
here it just happens to be the proposed
instantiation here so we've seen how
much the auricle costs are least an
upper bound on that that's for a
slightly non-uniform distribution to
that but there is some good reason to
think that a similar cost should be
attainable for a uniform superposition
mention that at the end okay so but
focusing on the SIB costs so abstracting
away the auricle the original Seaside
paper estimates something like 2 to the
62 Oracle queries for reg gives low low
space but higher query algorithm and the
SID memories polynomial some work by
bond attain and stron lower looked at KU
Berg's original algorithm and came to
this number for the number of queries
with a that many qubits and then you can
ask okay for the third algorithm that
the one that subsumes the prior to
what's the estimate well there was
actually none available previously so
that's what we're gonna you know end to
fill fill this gap here
okay so we're gonna generalize and give
some practical improvements to Cooper
Brooks collimation Sivir C said for
short and then analyze what kind of
concrete numbers you get for proposed
parameters the kind of what I mean by
generalized and improve so we managed to
handle arbitrary group orders this is
using tricks that were or ideas that had
applied to the first algorithm they kind
of poured over to this this new setting
of the collimation sieve so generalizing
from power of two order group orders
will show a way to recover several
secret bits from each run of the sieve
which is which was also done for the
earlier algorithm but it hadn't been I
don't think written down for the new one
some tricks to control them the time
complexities and the memory complexities
and we actually run some simulations up
to and including the exact group order
of seaside 512 so we can actually
stimulate the sieve algorithm or at
least the classical part of it
simulate it fully on real experiments
that's what we did and the takeaway is
that the simulations basically comport
extremely closely to the theoretical
model that we give so you can give good
predictions for how many queries are
needed how much RAM is needed based on
these simulations okay so then the
takeaway I already mentioned some of
these points but you know using this
much key rack'em so increasing amounts
of queue rack'em knocks down the number
of Oracle queries correspondingly so if
you have you know a good deal more queue
rack'em then you can even get close to
two of the 14 Oracle queries beating two
to the
any questions about this
and then it turns out that at the same
time we were doing this work bonnet
chain and Shroud lower were extending
their previous work they give a
theoretical analysis for a actually a
very different point on the parameter
spectrum of a collimation sieve they end
up at roughly similar conclusions about
the complexity so we've seen this before
though let me just refresh on how a CRS
style crypto system can be attacked to
be a hidden shift so the hidden shift
problem is you have two functions from a
group additive group to some arbitrary
set C and these functions are related by
some hidden shift s and the goal is to
find shift so Child's Jones sukharev say
okay here's how we do it we have the
base value and we have the public key
and we just define the two functions as
you know G maps to Z by just multiplying
or you starring G into the corresponding
neither the base value or the public key
respectively and you can just write out
the equations it turns out that these
two functions are related by this shift
and so if you can solve hidden shift
problem for these two functions you
recover the secret key so we have now
these two functions just given the
public key and the base value and now we
can if you can implement the Oracle for
these two functions then you can run the
collimation sivan so i'd like to just
give you kind of the main ideas behind
the the update to the collimation sieve
that we do we're going to sieve on what
we'll call the high bits rather than the
low bits and this will have some
advantages in terms of simplicity and
handling arbitrary group orders so we
have some let's suppose we have some
finite cyclic group of you know an order
n isomorphic to Z mod N and this
collimation sieve algorithm is going to
work with these quantum states which are
called phase vectors and each phase
vector has some vector of what are
called phase multipliers
so originally we will be given from from
our Oracle or with a little bit of help
from our Oracle will be given fresh
phase vectors and these fresh vectors
have huge random multipliers so their
multipliers are in interval 0 to n favor
n is the group order and we can ask for
or we can construct phase vectors of any
desired length L as long as we can write
it down
you know feasibly with are within our
queue rack'em so think of this L is the
amount of Q Rackham that you have so
you're given these initial fresh phase
vectors but they have nasty huge
multipliers our goal is to construct a
very nice phase vector which has small
multipliers so by small I mean the
multipliers should be roughly bounded by
L ok so we want to construct a phase
vector blank L those multipliers are
also less than L so we start with these
these huge multipliers and our original
phase vectors we want to whittle them
down and from this we can extract secret
qubits so how will we do this we're
going to make a nicer progressively
nicer phase vectors with multipliers
that live in successively smaller
intervals ok so we're just going to chop
down the the range if you will of where
the multipliers live by big chunk using
this process called collimation
questions so far it was kind of similar
to what we've what we've seen David
talked about but the new object here is
these phase vectors which will give us a
lot of a lot more a lot more juice to
squeeze Victoria Lee here's the picture
it's gonna look something like this so
we can imagine some binary tree or
higher arity tree but for now let's just
think about binary tree and we're gonna
fix some sequence of interval sizes so
at the root we would like to have a
phase vector whose multipliers are in
this interval but we can only construct
at first phase vectors whose multipliers
are in this big interval here
so if you imagine kind of arranging
things so that I'm getting a little bit
ahead of myself okay so at the leaves
we have bracket N and as the root we
want to get to bracket s0 and roughly
speaking the ratio between adjacent s is
here should be about L so this tells you
is the depth of the tree is about log n
divided by log L
okay so good so how would the the set of
proceed
well the leaf at the leaf nodes you're
going to get some fresh length L phase
vector with multipliers in bracket n and
then you're going to in each internal
node you're going to collimate its
children okay the child vectors that the
vectors at it's two children you
collimate them and that's going to cut
down the size or the interval of the
multipliers by about a L factor and you
can do this in a variety of ways you
could do it by like a depth-first search
so start with this take this column ate
it to get that handle these to collimate
it to get that colonize those to get
that and so forth you could do at depth
breadth first which would be more
parallel but more more memory
requirements you could do something that
in between but this is the the picture
of okay and so the key insight is as I
already mentioned is the more Q rack'em
we have the larger we can take this L
and that's going to decrease the depth
and thereby require fewer vectors and
fewer Oracle calls associated with the
leaf that's the key trick here so I
don't have too much time right couple
minutes okay so let me tell you what a
phase vector is at least and then
so for the secret s here's a phase
vector of length L it's just some
quantum state where we're proportional
to so we have L cats here basically so
we have a l basis vectors basis elements
and then associated to J we have a phase
term which is basically some B of J
times s over N and as B of J is known as
the phase multiplier for J so it's
there's just some function from L to
let's say bracket n which tells you what
the phase multipliers are so for example
this is something we've already seen
before in a special case at least if you
invoke the Oracle that David told us
about this morning then you get a single
qubit which looks like this and it turns
out this is really just a length to
phase vector so B of 0 is just 0 which
gives you a phase of you know just a
factor of 1 here and then and then you
have this phase term here which is as
multiplier of paper so you know if you
can invoke the Oracle you get a length 2
phase vector of this special form and in
general we would store a larger phase
vectors we know their multipliers so
those are known classically we would
just store them in a sorted list so it
takes you know quasi linear and an L
number of bits to store those phase
multipliers but only log L qubits for
the quantum state itself and this is
basically the the core of where the
exponential improvement in quantum space
comes from
so this looks scary but there's actually
nothing going on here we can take two
phase vectors and combine them you just
tensor them together okay then you get a
new phase vector essentially a new phase
vector with all pair sums of the phase
multipliers so it's a big ugly equation
but nothing's really interesting going
on here
so we have this new phase vector with
essentially now it's the product of the
two lengths is its is its length and the
sums of its various phase multipliers
are its new other than your phase
multipliers for example if you take a
few fresh qubits from the auricle and
just tensor them together you get this
length 2 to the L phase vector and it's
multipliers are the subset sums of the
individual labels that's a simple thing
you can do more interestingly you can do
what's called collimation collimation is
the main main kind of procedure here
behind the sieve so I'll just show this
briefly with collimation you have two
phase vectors let's suppose they have
length L roughly and they're on some
large size s Prime
interval their multipliers are from that
interval then the goal is to combine
them into one phase vector of roughly
the same length but on a significantly
smaller interval so s will now be cut
down by about an L factor so the way we
do this well we just tensor the phase
vectors as I showed this now gives you a
much longer phase vector which has
multipliers of the pair sums and then
you're going to do this very clever idea
you're going to measure this this new
combined phase vector according to the
quotient of the multiplier divided by s
and then round it so what does this do
well it says basically it's going to
kill off all the phase multipliers
except for those which have this
quotient and so the only surviving
multipliers are those while they're
remainders basically remainders when
divided by s
are in this interval here there's some
global phase which doesn't affect
basically all the surviving multipliers
are now in this this smaller interval
and then you have to do some bookkeeping
to make this a proper phase vector but
the key point here is that if this
combined phase vector here has length L
squared its multipliers are pretty well
distributed over to s Prime and so
heuristic aliy at least most of the size
s sub intervals here have about L
multipliers in them so when you do this
measurement here you're going to end up
with about L surviving multipliers and
they will effectively have they will
effectively be in the interval s and at
step 3 is where the work is done this
requires some constant number of lookups
into the queue rack'em of size L and
then some quasi linear so I will skip
the regularization amount and
measurement part but basically it says
once you get a phase vector with very
small multipliers roughly the same size
as the length then you can do a qft to
extract about log s bits of secret so
you get several actually by doing it
this way to get several bits of the
secret out at a time and then you can
run the sieve more times to get more of
the bits of the secret out so there's
some practical issues that came up in
the simulations which are not terribly
interesting from a theoretical point of
view but to make the thing actually run
we have to address these and I'll finish
with the open questions and I have a lot
of the same questions that Chloe had
from before lunch so really the key
question is like what's the complexity
of the of the Seaside Oracle we can now
get very good confidence on how many
Oracle queries are needed to run a full
attack but you know what do we know
about the Oracle the existing estimates
are not for the uniform distribution
they're for a slightly non-uniform one
so can you bridge that gap
or do you need to bridge that gap maybe
they're not maybe the slightly
non-uniform is somehow good enough we
have some evidence that you can handle
the uniform distribution by reducing in
a certain lattice where we have a lot of
short relations that are known so it'd
be interesting to bound the overall cost
and depth of this this kind of procedure
that would actually give you the uniform
distribution and then I think an
interesting question is can you more
directly construct a quantum circuit for
the seaside function the existing
constructions you know just build a
classical circuit and then convert it
generically I don't know this maybe this
is maybe there's nothing to this but
we're making a lot of oracle calls can
we amortize them some way can we get our
initial phase vectors at least in some
more clever way than just getting a
bunch of individual qubits and combining
them that would speed up things and then
a separate question which I don't think
has been raised before is can we break
seaside using partial information about
the secret because when you run the
sieve you get log S bits out maybe it's
35 or something like that so you get
several bits out our estimates for the
number of Oracle calls or for recovering
almost all the bits of the secret but
maybe getting half of the bits is enough
to break the scheme and we move a lot of
you know a lot of schemes don't do well
under a secret key leakage of partial
leakage so that would also cut down the
number of Oracle calls you have to make
so that's that's all
oh if you want to run the code you there
it is quick question
[Applause]